[Musica]
c'era una volta tanto tempo fa
il dio supremo vicino il quale vedendo
che c'era disordine sulla terra decise
che era giunto il momento di mettere un
po di ordine ma il problema di capire
come scendere dalla dimensione divina
alla dimensione terrestre ed essendo lui
ovviamente il dio supremo ebbe
l'intuizione divina di moltiplicarsi in
dieci forme diverse in dieci alla tara
l'avatar e quindi la soluzione che il
dio vicino ha trovato per avere il dono
dell'ubiquità e trasportarsi da una
dimensione all'altra
vi racconto questa storia perché se ci
pensate bene anche noi oggi viviamo in
una situazione simile a quella del dio
vishnu e cioè viviamo in due dimensioni
in due mondi mondo reale e quello
digitale
difatti se penso alla generazione dei
miei genitori è stata l'ultima che ho
potuto vivere almeno per la maggior
parte della loro vita
soltanto nella dimensione reale
e poi ci sono io in quanto millenial ho
vissuto in pieno la nascita del web e
l'arrivo degli smartphone ed il bivio
dimensionale e questi hanno generato e
poi c'è la generazione dei miei figli
praticamente dove oggi anche davanti a
un televisore cercano di zoomare le
immagini con le dita come se fosse un
touch screen
insomma per la prima volta senza
precedenti storici nell'evoluzione
dell'uomo in sole tre generazioni è
cambiato il mondo per vivere grazie
soprattutto alla ad internet
l'uomo avuto accesso a una quantità di
informazioni pazzesca e la possibilità
di interagire con il resto del mondo
per esempio noi oggi possiamo comunicare
o meglio diciamo che perderci dentro i
social network facendoci gli affari
degli altri
oppure possiamo chiacchierare con degli
amici in video conference che vivono
dall'altra parte del mondo in australia
o meglio ancora potremmo
visitare un museo pechino in realtà
virtuale insomma tutto questo mondo
digitale è divertente ma c'è come in
tutte le cose arriva un momento in cui
questo entusiasmo si placa e torniamo
con i piedi per terra perché io non
voglio giudicare se tutto questo è
giusto o sbagliato ma non possiamo
negare il fatto che tutto il tempo che
noi dedichiamo alla dimensione digitale
ci distrae dalla vita reale
non so voi se non è sempre più spesso mi
capita di vivere situazioni del genere
e importante quindi far sì che la
tecnologia sia a supporto della vita
reale senza però soppiantarla sempre più
spesso ma più passa il tempo più faccio
fatica a stare dietro a questa a questa
dimensione digitale a volte mi sento
bombardato da mille informazioni che mi
arrivano da tutte le parti e non vi nego
che a volte mi viene voglia di dire
basta di prendere il telefono di
lanciarlo contro il muro semplicemente
per avere un po di silenzio e laurent
tutta questa digitalità è paragonabile a
un onda anomala che rischia di
travolgerci io credo però che noi
abbiamo la possibilità di poterla
cavalcare e di poterla cavalcare
divertendoci e sapete qual è la
soluzione è semplice
la soluzione è fare un copia incolla
dell'idea del dio vishnu e quindi avere
come lui il nostro avatar
per fare ordine nella nostra dimensione
digitale
ma prima di parlarvi di avatar vorrei
condividere una riflessione una
riflessione sul fatto che secondo me si
è già aperta una nuova era che a me
piace definire umanesimo digitale
sì perché rispetto a 600 anni fa all
umanesimo di 600 anni fa dove l'uomo
dove dopo un periodo buio il quad durato
quasi dieci secoli la figura dell'uomo è
stata riportata al centro del pensiero
filosofico e sociale le scoprendo così
la valorizzazione delle individualità e
del talento di ognuno di noi
tutto questo ha innescato un
accelerazione nel progresso soprattutto
nell'arte nella cultura nella scienza
per arrivare così fino ai giorni d'oggi
con la cosiddetta rivoluzione digitale
bene oggi a differenza del seicento anni
fa
io credo che l'uomo non abbia più
bisogno di essere al centro di un mondo
che gli gira attorno
piuttosto abbiamo bisogno che l'uomo sia
centrato e che lui sappia bene che è
parte del mondo di questo mondo che gira
gira comunque con o senza di lui
e allora questo umanesimo 2.0 questo
nuovo umanesimo digitale ci mette
davanti al fatto che noi dobbiamo
guardare al futuro
da una prospettiva diversa una
prospettiva collaborativa una
prospettiva evolutiva non più
individualista non più ecocentri solo
così potremo trovare quell'equilibrio
per poter vivere con il mondo che ci
circonda e io sinceramente da padre di
due meravigliose creature mi sento la
responsabilità di poter dar loro ed alle
generazioni future un nuovo mezzo un
nuovo strumento per poter semplicemente
cercare questo equilibrio e navigare in
questo nuovo mare digitale che secondo
me è tutto da far fare e allora
permettetemi di dire grazie al dio
vishnu per averci suggerito un'idea così
brillante pare l'avatar il vero eroe
dell'umanesimo digitale la
rappresentazione pratica concreta e
immediata delle soluzioni per mettere
ordine nella nostra dimensione digitale
adesso vi spiego meglio presentendo io
per avatar
o meglio avatar isee shaun che altro non
è che il processo
di convertirci in vite per poter vivere
nella dimensione digitale avatar is the
show nel realizzare una perfetta copia
digitale in 3d fotorealistica della
nostra figura un altro io ma fatto di
bit che possa muoversi ed interagire nel
mondo digitale come mio come il mio io
reale vive nella vita quotidiana di
tutti i giorni
allora viene semplice immaginare come
tutte quelle attività digitali che noi
svolgiamo nel nostro quotidiano possono
essere semplificate all'atari session è
anche un progetto a cui ho impegnato gli
ultimi 4 anni del mio lavoro e di quello
di altri nemici millennio
orgogliosamente tutti italiani devo dire
quattro anni in cui abbiamo studiato e
analizzato tutte le tecnologie di
scansione individuando poi alla fine la
tecnologia fotogrammetrica quella che
faceva il nostro caso ma adesso vi
faccio vedere che cosa abbiamo fatto in
questi ultimi quattro anni dove abbiamo
provato a sviluppare aveva iniziato a
sviluppare i primi prototipi si era
visto prima
abbiamo iniziato a costruire dei propri
e veri studi fotogrammetrici abbiamo
siamo migliorati abbiamo acquisito know
how e abbiamo un certo punto preso
questa tecnologia e l'abbiamo plasmata
sulla forma dell'uomo ed è venuta fuori
una forma ad uovo simbolo di nascita
digitale per arrivare ad un body scanner
automatico che la porta di accesso per
entrare nel mondo digitale dove
attraverso un semplice click
scattiamo da decine e decine di camere
sincronizzate una fotografia di noi
dopodiché parte un processo che il
processo della creazione dell'avatar che
è per una e magico dove queste immagini
ad alta definizione vengono elaborate da
degli algoritmi
per ricrearsi fedelmente in un ambiente
3d dove manteniamo le nostre
informazioni che sono uniche e creiamo
il nostro avatar
il risultato è fotorealistico al colore
della nostra pelle e misurabile abbiamo
la nostra morfologia poi c'è la parte di
vestizione ed infine inseriamo uno
scheletro digitale per potergli dare il
dono del movimento per poterlo muovere
ed ecco che abbiamo creato il nostro
avatar adesso probabilmente vi starete
chiedendo se io che a billy va bene ma
ancora non abbiamo capito come l'avatar
può semplificarci la vita e mettere un
po di ordine e allora permettetemi di
mostrarvi qualche esempio semplice e
veloce che di quello che ci siamo
immaginati
ma sul quale già oggi noi stiamo
lavorando per far sì che presto diventi
realtà il primo campo d'applicazione il
gaming
sì perché con il nostro avatar noi
possiamo divertirci possiamo entrare nel
vivo di un gioco ancora oggi a distanza
ormai più di vent'anni solo i grandi
campioni
solo chi ha i piedi buoni può divertirsi
con il proprio avatar
bene io sinceramente i piedi buoni non
ce li ho mai avuti
ma il mio avatar si guardate qui sono
riuscito ad entrare in un gioco
ho giocato
con permesso di giocare in una delle
tante squadre più forti del mondo che è
il barcellona
e sono anche riuscito a fare un gol
novantesimo minuto contro l'inter
la mia squadra arrivare da sempre un
altro esempio un altro campo di
applicazione è la moda nel mondo del
fashion grazie all'avatar ne possiamo
semplificare il processo di acquisto
online
sì perché abbiamo detto che l'avatar
alle nostre misure alla nostra
morfologia le nostre informazioni e
quindi ci può dare quella sicurezza che
quando acquistiamo su un ecommerce
sappiamo che quel prodotto e della
taglia giusta giusta e quindi andiamo a
risolvere il problema dei resi sia per
noi ma anche per le aziende ma i
vantaggi non sono non finiscono qui
perché per esempio potranno condividere
le nostre informazioni con il nostro
sarto operano preferito per
commissionargli dei capi su misura o
meglio ancora è l'avatar può diventare
il nostro personal shopper e provare per
noi dei capi 3d che corrispondono a dei
capi e reali facendo così noi abilitiamo
le aziende di moda a poter iniziare a
pensare di produrre direttamente sul
venduto perché andiamo ad ottimizzare
tutti quei processi come la
prototipazione la produzione la
logistica rendendo il sistema della moda
molto più sostenibile non solo in
termini economici ma soprattutto
ambientali adesso vi mostro che cosa ha
provato il mio avatar per me m'hanno
scusate questo è un capo che voleva
provarsi mia moglie mi ha detto che lei
non ancora su avatar le ho apprezzato il
mio
[Musica]
invece questo è un apposito da uomo
adatto per un'occasione
[Musica]
allora adesso passiamo invece un altro
campo di applicazione un campo di
applicazione che riguarda la salute
dell'uomo come per esempio il wellness
sì perché attraverso più scansioni nel
tempo
noi possiamo monitorare come cambia il
nostro corpo vedete chi chi mi conosce
lo sa
a me piace mangiare e io qualche mese fa
ero sinceramente un po in sovrappeso
allora ho fatto la scansione ho
condiviso il mio avatar con la palestra
con il personal trainer nutrizionista il
quale ha elaborato i miei dati ea mi ha
creato un percorso di lavoro sono
migliorato ho rifatto la scansione
abbiamo messo a confronto
due modelli i due avatar se andate a
vedere dove sono migliorato dove no e
hanno potuto per ottimizzarne il piano
di rotunno e poi abbiamo anche sono dati
on
abbiamo fatto una previsione di come
potrei diventare e non vi nego che per
me è stimolante tutto questo perché io
tutte le mattine guardo il mio avatar
bello del futuro è piuttosto che fornire
ancora mezz'oretta prendo e me ne vado
ancora da un altro campo è il campo
medicale nel campo medicale a verona va
per avere con la cartella clinica che è
la nostra forma le nostre informazioni
la nostra morfologia delle nostre
immagini ad alta risoluzione
quindi viene semplice immaginare come
noi potremmo condividere tutti questi
dati con gli ospedali i medici
l'università potremo contribuire a
creare un dustin stata 20 corpi digitali
che corrisponde alla popolazione reale
per aiutare la ricerca pensiamo anche a
siamo più come l'ortopedia dove andiamo
a togliere il gesso grazie a tutori e
protesi stampati in trenino lavater può
diventare per esempio per i
fisioterapisti uno strumento per
effettuare cercato posturali per
monitorare dei percorsi di
riabilitazione o in campo dermatologico
per esempio può diventare uno strumento
di prevenzione perché grazie alla
scansione potrà fare una mappatura dei
nei
magari il nostro stesso avatar ci potrà
indicare se quello è impossibile
melanoma è detto dovremo andare a
prendere tempestivamente
l'appuntamento col dermatologo insomma
questi sono soltanto alcuni esempi di
quello che ci siamo immaginato ma
immaginate marche è già in work in
progress ma i campi d'applicazione sono
potenzialmente infiniti perché tutto
quello che viene studiato progettato ho
realizzato sul luogo ha un senso se
pensiamo alla rata ma cerchiamo ora di
immaginare un po più in là in un mondo
fatto di tecnologie sempre più veloci
coinvolgenti complesse tecnologie che
sono tra di noi o che stanno arrivando
come la realtà virtuale
la realtà aumentata 5 g la brooks chain
l'intelligenza artificiale tutte
tecnologie che possono secondo me dare i
superpoteri al nostro avatar
e magari un domani nostro avatar potrà
non so prenotarci un ristorante
indicando al ristoratore
il nostro piano alimentare oppure
prenotarci un viaggio al mare ed
acquistare per noi un attrezzatura
sportiva creata su misura per noi o
meglio ancora potremmo parlare con il
nostro avatar come se fosse un vero e
proprio assistente e magari lui stesso
potrà rispondere alle mail per noi lo
sai che bello
insomma sinceramente io credo che così
come 25 anni fa del cellulare non
sapevano esattamente cosa farci
così fra molto meno di 25 anni ognuno di
noi avrà un altro se digitale un avatar
per risparmiare tempo
denaro ed energie spero quindi che voi
possiate approcciare questo questa
dimensione digitale con più serenità
consapevoli che l'avatar sarà un
compagno di viaggio che vive nel
digitale per mettere ordine e per
cavalcare quest'onda come non mai
insomma per avere più tempo per la vita
reale e perché no vivere meglio il
momento presente
grazie
[Applauso]